government has no authority to infringe
upon that right if you are a law-abiding
citizen right they solely exist to
protect those rights the moment there is
an enforcement of policy that have
infringes upon your basic fundamental
human rights resistance is at least an
appropriate discussion want to talk
about this this uh this idea of people
now are labeling anyone who criticizes
the government or accuses policies of
being tyrannical I'm making death
threats yeah and I think the discussion
that we actually should have a lot of
people don't want to have it because no
one wants to be tarred and feathered as
someone who's an extremist we're suing
guess that's no one here is issuing
death threats wanna be really clear
right happier but I've heard me say this
repeatedly on good Ally covers so let's
start it with this bait oo Rourke for in
case you think of another bait oh I knew
a bait Oh back in junior high but I
don't think he proposed a gun buyback
bait oh he repeated his demands for a
mandatory gun buyback program at the
debates this Tuesday listening to my
fellow Americans to those moms who
demand action to those students who
marched for our lives who in fact came
up with this extraordinary bold thank
you kinda that calls for mandatory
buybacks
let's follow their inspiration and lead
let's just follow their inspiration no
no doesn't matter how much of a
violation if you can rise it as long as
you were inspired it doesn't matter just
do it look at some nice watercolors oh
my gosh and just to be clear we want to
make sure that we are not taking him out
of context I encourage you to go watch
the full debates the next day when asked
about it he doubled down on his comments
in that case I think there would be a
visit by law enforcement to remember
that firearm and to make sure it was
purchased bought back so that it cannot
be potentially used against somebody
else because you would never want a
firearm to potentially be used against
someone else know that almost might
negate the purpose of fire
yes now keep in mind by the way while
we're talking - beta was arrested for
burglary and had a DUI fled the scene so
the guy proposing this is somebody who
was burbling golden you know you want a
great kid
Fred Lazaro beta we thinking keep it
down for better huh this isn't it's
important to note even at the Democratic
debates I think that's why I doubled
down the next day yeah the Democrats
went out of their way they wanted to
challenge him on this and I think this
stems from but bado was struggling I
think to get one or two percent in the
woods yeah yeah and so you know what
Democrats obviously are pushing through
this I'm just gonna come out and say
mandatory gun buyback gun confiscation
that was a Hail Mary and Democrats are
gonna oh we can just pick this guy off
more effectively than Jessica ever
picked off Kamala Harris more debates
ago which by the way Tulsi Gabbard I
actually think the only two reasonable
people on that stage and ranked LCG but
Tulsi Gabbard has no chance she's too
hot you can't have a president who's
that attractive people we're comfortable
around it notably Justin Trudeau he's
gonna be competing sizing up sort of
Mean Girls so the Democrats went after I
want to make sure that we show a clip
they went after Nate O'Rourke saying oh
okay better how are you going to enforce
that it's unenforceable our fellow
Americans will follow a lot yes mass
shooters in parkland in El Paso I could
go on for ten minutes they don't follow
the law by definition nice a big digis
yeah you don't know how this is actually
going to take weapons off the streets if
you can develop the plan further I think
we can have a debate about it you can't
debate about it knowing this you know
last week the left they had a meltdown
claiming that Ben Shapiro had threatened
to murder someone because he did say
that he would resist the Democratic
agenda if it violated basic human rights
I want you to watch the clip now full
disclosure I'm friends with Ben Shapiro
I've known him for a while I was like he
negotiated my first business contrary
yeah we just met through Andrew
Breitbart and I said you know you've got
a lot of vowels in your last name and
you seem like you can negotiate this
court work out and I didn't know Bill at
the time of such Shapiro just what yes I
am biased but I want you to watch the
clip for yourself and see if he made a
death threat in any shape or form
there's only one reason the government
exists to protect those rights not
invade those rights
it is my rights raise my child with the
moral precepts that I find to be
beneficial for my child they don't work
does not get to raise my child and if he
tries I will meet him at the door with a
gun I don't he's basically just amateurs
in Scenario he's talking about
protecting exactly he's not
about threatening he's not going out to
look for beta O'Rourke he's saying look
if you come and try to invade my face
and try to tell me how to do this I'm
going to protect myself right I mean I
think the one thing I would say that is
at least intellectually honest about
what Vado saying is that he's admitting
that the plan that he has been talking
about and that other Democrats have
talked about will lead to using guns to
seize other guns for people who aren't
using their guns wrong and so finally
admitting it and now even the left is
admitting it's not really a plan that
will make sense in any kind of efficacy
type of way absolutely that's that's a
fact
it does beg the question when if ever is
armed resistance required or appropriate
and how is drawing a line in the sand on
that basis when you how is that
different from a death threat again
half-asian bill my lawyer not making any
death threats I am NOT issuing any call
to violence here with this segment okay
right he's not okay okay so let's go
through point one except in this
conversation because to think that no to
think that resistance or to think that
some kind of armed resistance or armed
violent conflict can't happen today is
naive right it's to not understand bake
the basic human condition it happens
across the world today by the way
slavery still happens today and we'll
get back to that this idea that we're
well past that so we don't need guns
anymore is that it's so factually off
being that it's the actual we need
firearms because you learn to protect
one's self in the modern world is with
firearms and that's why it's a god-given
right so let's look at the history as to
what in the past throughout history
humans thought warranted some kind of
resistance right and differentiating
that let's differentiate that from
senseless violence
so one let's take an example here and
say a death threat versus setting a line
in the sand right boundary okay so one
like saying if someone breaks into my
house in the middle of night while I in
my family are there I'm going to protect
it with my firearm yeah okay reasonable
that's issuing a line putting it drawing
a line in the sand creating boundaries
the other a death threat would be saying
I'm gonna kill it aware of the post
office ones appropriate ones are
reprehensible crime yeah when we look at
history there are three lines as to when
people have resorted to armed resistance
legitimately right usually it requires
the invasive removal of very
personal human rights I'll give you a
few examples here of course with the
American Revolution you can see freedom
of religion was a big one never wanted
to be able to worship freely the
government was not representative of its
of its constituents taxation without
representation then that mirror is quite
a bit what happened with the French
Revolution right we have the civil war
over slavery I would argue that's a good
thing someone was trying to say you are
going to be enslaved I'm going to remove
your right to be free and there was a
call to arms which is also why we have
the Second Amendment
in the first place as far as the
guesswork I like to take it out of this
equation here but which rights are worth
fighting over
um we have a guide to our Stars if you
want the Constitution and it expressly
outlines human rights natural rights
human rights is granted by God that's
what's important here you may just think
it's some some imaginary being this guy
that's fine but you still benefit from
the idea that the founding the premise
that the founding fathers used to
establish the Bill of Rights the
Constitution they said this is the
government cannot grant or remove these
rights they can only exist to protect
them
so again when if ever is armed
resistance appropriate and can someone
discuss in 2019 without being accused of
a death threat speaking of death our
channel is actually still alive and well
thanks to you get the notification bell
if you're subscribed because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
just bookmark the page new video every
single day if you want this content to
continue join my club letter cutter comm
slash my club so let me kind of make
this clear and then you guys can
obviously chime in sure when would it be
appropriate let's start with when it
would be inappropriate okay when would
it be inappropriate to ever defend
yourself or mount some kind of
resistance okay
it would be inappropriate for any kind
of violent resistance due to a personal
affront due to policy differences due to
ad hominem attacks or even due to a
proposal of a policy that you think
could lead to tyranny none of those
would be appropriate instances to stand
your ground okay and there's there's
some nuance in there obviously let me
tell you where it gets black and white
there ceases to be nuance the moment
there is an enforcement of policy that
have infringes upon your basic
fundamental human rights resistance is
at least an appropriate discussion so
we've said where it's not appropriate
let me give you some clear examples what
I think
to be appropriate let's start with with
bait or work going house-to-house to
take people's guns yes which is he has
to do that right we're not talking about
an assault weapons ban you know we
should basically means like okay this
this is legal illegal
you've broken no law Oritel might
house-to-house take a gun let me clip
you broken no law it is your personal
property you have the right to own that
gun correct and everything else the
government has no authority to infringe
upon that right if you are a law-abiding
citizen right they solely exist to
protect those rights so let me give you
another example if some person has
seized a have no right decides that they
want to rewrite laws so that they can
simply infringe upon your god-given
rights it's illegitimate yeah I won't
recognize that just a Miss it just is in
the same way if someone walks into my
house who's an intruder he has not been
granted permission and like a vampire I
didn't invite him in if I do it's on me
it's on me I'm gonna be pale in the face
I get it it's a rule right if he comes
in he does not have the right to take
any of my stuff
including my firearm neither does a
member of the government they do not
have the right to do that just because
someone said I am going to create a new
law let's compare it to the freedom of
speech scenario okay but let's kind of
go on that flip side of the coin here so
I have the right to speak freely that's
recognizing the Constitution what does
that mean if I am out speaking against
the government let's say I matter
right-to-life rally yeah okay let's just
say I'm speaking offensively for example
I don't know using your biologically
proper pronouns so so offensive cancel
just because it offends somebody doesn't
mean they have the right to punch me in
the face and I can't come up throw a
concrete milkshake I have the right to
defend myself with appropriate force
yeah equal an opposing reaction right
that would be no different than if I
went out and spoke against the
government and they sent armed people to
jail me those are not removing my right
to speak freely enshrined in the
Constitution by force I believe that in
that instance it is appropriate to
defend yourself these are extreme
examples at least they would have been
theoretical examples except for the fact
that beta work brought it to the wall as
a very concrete example he would send
people house to help you take your guns
with their own guns made it very clear
the government has no authority and
telling me what I can and can't
not say just because a new politician
says they can it doesn't mean that I'm
actually breaking the law it's a natural
law it's a human right it is not a
political policy and I'd like to toss a
bill on that a little bit people don't
understand the idea of of natural rights
human rights these are birthright
well they're the idea that the rights
themselves are outside of or above and
not given by government because at some
point when you say that the government
is the one that can create the rights
and those rights don't pre-exists the
government so not only have you unhinge
the idea of rights except for someone
who's giving it to you but you have no
way to say if a group of people get
together and say yeah you actually don't
have any rights anymore so in my house
right I mean they just that's that's the
kind of natural thought that led back to
a Democratic lead fight for slavery you
know a century go when did I lose that
right kickflip yeah freedom of religion
right to worship freely yeah I don't get
Muslim Christian Jewish signs how it
doesn't matter if some random guy comes
into my church or your mosque with a gun
yes right telling you that the Flying
Spaghetti Monster has led to more Wars
than bah bah bah bah bah bah bah okay we
get it everyone who says it's like we
understand that you took humanities 101
this is about we have the right to
defend ourselves as someone walks into a
mosque or a church with a gun why
because it's a natural human right they
cannot tell us how we can worship now if
the government does that same thing in
saying listen I'm sorry this is what ben
shapiro was speaking to you can't take
your child to that christian school you
have to send him to our public school
you can't teach your son that theology
it has to match our new tolerant
guidelines and they attempt to enforce
it which bado is really clear about
means people door to door with guns yeah
resistance is an appropriate discussion
at that point to have not a call to arms
not a death threat context context
context let's the young turks try and
take this clip and say call to arms i
want to make sure really clear the
government at that point is no different
than the man entering a mosque with a
gun to try and stop you from worshipping
freely this is about establishing
boundaries yeah okay more importantly
it's about engaging everyone here not
only in this room but if you're watching
in a discussion about boundaries so that
we can set them before they are crossed
in order to avoid any violent con
all right when you set boundaries and
people know that those boundaries exist
for example if someone says listen if
I'm a law-abiding citizen and you send
someone in my house with a gun well my
family's there to try and take my stuff
whether it's my flatscreen I was gonna
say plasma I don't think plasmas I hope
that was a measure each with their own
50-inch plasma screen
oh damn unfettered capitalism now I can
get it at Walmart a Westinghouse for $40
anyway but if someone for me to say
listen to someone with a gun comes into
my house to take my property whether
it's a TV or a gun no this is I'm not
going to a lot I will meet you at the
door with the gun that is a boundary
that is a line in the sand that if
someone knows actually assist them in
avoiding some kind of a violent conflict
absolutely because if you don't set
boundaries you're often the last to know
when you've crossed them or they've been
crossed your your basic human rights
birth rights defending them is
completely justifiable I don't think
it's controversial you know good if the
government just said we had slavery in
this country terrible context contest
slavery bad okay when I cancelled again
we had slavery so it's not in their
slavery across the globe the government
were to say slavery's back you can
resist that I think it's an appropriate
response resist it violently in that
instance and I would be with black
people if they wanted to put y'all back
and change right like why because the
government doesn't have the right to
enslave people we only know that now
because we fought over that it was a
resistance I'm ok with that
do you like this video subscribe hit the
notification bell to stay in the loop
there were videos playing in boxes but I
was just enjoying my pipe and this pipe
was actually purchased through your
support at mug club because we don't
make any money off of youtube bladder
with CARICOM flash mug club not only do
you get access to the entire blaze
catalog this wonderful hand etched mug
but hours of content that you don't get
to see or find or search here on YouTube
in other words if you want the show to
continue you join mug club and then I'll
expand my pipe collection